hi and welcome to this microsoft
research webinar
i'm sai vamprala and i'm a researcher
with the autonomous systems group at
microsoft
and today i would like to talk to you
about the role of simulation in ai
and specifically our open source
robotics simulator offering that we call
microsoft airsim
over the course of this webinar i would
like to introduce the features of airsim
and also go through some sample research
projects that i've used and benefit from
airsome features in the past
and towards the end of this webinar i'd
also like to go through a quick demo of
aerosome features
so you as a researcher can get started
with using it
so a little bit about the autonomous
systems group and myself so i've been a
researcher with microsoft for a little
less than a year now
and before that i got my phd working on
the idea of collaborative drones
uh typically localization planning and
more classical robotics things
and at the autonomous systems group my
focus is on
um what we call colloquially training
brains for robots or these are the
decision making pipelines that drive
the robot's actions so to this end i
examine things like robust neural
networks
uh learning invariant representations
for robots and also the idea of bridging
the simulation reality gap using
simulators like airsim
so to begin with as a primer i'm gonna
talk about autonomous robotics in
general and what are the challenges that
require
airsim as a simulation right so as we
all know
autonomous systems today have a large
area of applications and some of the
most popular ones in them are things
like self-driving cars
uh and for example drones that are
supposed to be doing package deliveries
and things like that
so as we can see many of these
applications involve a certain proximity
to humans and
also for example industrial equipment
and one thing we have to note is for
robotics specifically
there is the autonomy aspect of it which
can be treated as decision making
and then for every decision the robot
makes there is a corresponding action
which is like the actuation or the
movement of the robot
so combining the fact that it's moving
and what i just described above that
it's proximity to humans and things like
that
it is extremely important to focus on
things like safety and robustness so
that is not something we can compromise
over
so whatever policies that we use
whatever actions the robot takes have to
adhere to certain safety constraints
and at the same time when we think about
real life applications
the real world is hard to model right so
we have very complex sensing for example
even something as simple as a visual
camera
has a very complex input space and the
environments that the robots work are
quite diverse and the actions they take
are also
quite complicated so these are some
areas where machine learning
typically shines right so the idea is to
build autonomous systems by leveraging
these nice concepts in machine learning
that let us deal with complex data
spaces
and of course one of the challenges so
far is that autonomous systems research
is not
new so it's been around for a long time
and a lot of the focus
so far has been on classical techniques
so things like computer vision
and classical robotic pipelines have
been applied but of course as we move on
to more complex spaces
these are not sufficient so we'd have to
move to
more of a machine intelligence
perspective using neural networks and
deep learning
and so on and of course when we start
talking about deep learning or neural
networks in general
there is always a large dependency on
data so these are data-driven methods
for a reason
so we would have to you know come up
with some kind of label data for example
for supervised learning or if we start
talking about reinforcement learning and
such we need to have
places where the robot can explore and
understand the interactions with the
world
so considering the fact that the final
test case is going to be in real world
um it's really hard to have a scalable
method to get real world data for such a
large defense large dependence right so
it's it's almost impossible to get all
the corner cases right by training an
agent in the real world
so let's dig a little deeper into what
exactly is happening in autonomous
system
right so an autonomous system is
composed of what we call
a perception action loop and if you
think about it this is very similar to
what we humans do on a day-to-day basis
so a robot typically perceives the
environment around it this is
through the use of sensors typically and
on the picture on the left for example
you can see that the
there is a self-driving car that is
trying to look at some of the objects
around it like the other cars
signposts people etc and this perception
needs to result in an action and again
for the self-driving car this is
something like
um the steering commands or the throttle
and brake and so on
but the interesting thing here is that
the perception and action are quite
tightly coupled in robotics right so
every perception results in an action
and the action
also again drives the perception
subsequently after that
so what we need to do is we need to
learn these
loops in a very tightly coupled fashion
it's not enough to just focus on one
part of the task and then let the other
you know happen by itself
so the focus in a data-driven method
would be to learn these from both the
sensor data
as well as the corresponding
interactions so if we
look at some of the you know the typical
classes of learning and we have for
instance supervised learning
for supervised learning we would need
label data that is kind of task specific
um when we start thinking about
reinforcement learning for instance like
i mentioned before we would need to have
a sandbox that gives us
the ability to take actions and then
each action would have a reward
which is the typical rl paradigm and
then even if we consider something like
imitation learning which is like a
subset of
supervised then we would need uh for
example data traces of
what actions has an expert taken and the
imitation learning part is about
imitating an expert so we need expert
data and then we would have to take
those actions and then
train our agents correspondingly
so given these needs and challenges how
do we what is the most effective way to
train artificial intelligence for real
robotics and the biggest thing that pops
up is this dependence on data
right so here we look towards simulation
as a possible way forward
so as we all know modeling and
simulation
are one of the cornerstones of
engineering so whenever we talk about
any kind of a complex system for example
in the pictures here we have some
samples
think of for example an aircraft right
so most of the pilots
typically train on simulators before
they move to rail aircraft and when we
think about complex engineering systems
like computational fluid dynamics or
climate models or anything that is a
sufficiently complex system
one of the first things we do in
engineering is try to approximate it the
best way possible
and by characterizing it as well as we
can we have the luxury of getting a lot
more data without having to deal with
the
actually complex system so for things
like robotics or any
um real world engineering systems the
advantage is that
you know we don't we don't really care
about things crashing or breaking
because we have the luxury of just
restarting the simulation
and then learning from these failures as
time goes on
so even if we consider just machine
learning we have seen a lot of success
in the use of simulation and machine
learning concepts so for example a lot
of you may have seen the success of
reinforcement learning
in solving many of these video games or
games complex games like go and chess
right
so what we call these are like closed
world systems
that lets you simulate millions of
trials in a very easy fashion
so these agents can sort of learn from
their mistakes and learn the
mechanics of the games and then get
better and better until they even
achieve superhuman performance in some
cases
but the catch is that most of these
require many many frames of play right
for example
some of the initial work on atari
required about 10 million frames to get
to a reasonable level of performance
and then very recently there was
something called agent 57 released by
deepmind which
achieved superhuman performance on all
57 atari games
and this required for the max
performance about 80 billion frames of
play
and if you think about open ai 5 which
is the agent that successfully plays
dota 2 um this required something
equivalent to 45 000 years of dota self
play but of course i mean this is
uh this is being done in a very very
fast distributed fashion so it only
spread over about 10 months of real-time
training
but the the idea is that to get to this
level of performance and to get to this
level of robustness
it's always important to have a system
that you can use to the maximum so it's
something you can
explore and exploit and then come up
with these strategies and then find
which one works the best
so now our question has an answer so
why can't we kind of leverage these high
fidelity simulations
for robotics and i want to emphasize the
word high fidelity here because
when we start thinking about the real
world it's not like just a video game
right for example in the previous slide
we talked about these video games
that game that you're seeing on for
example on the bottom left the pac-man
that is the system that you want to
train on so the simulation is exactly
the same as your test case
but for robotics we have the real world
which is actually quite hard to
approximate
so we want to get as close as possible
in our characterization
and we want to build these large scale
accurate simulations so these machine
learning powered robots can learn
in these worlds and then we should be
able to transfer what we learn in terms
of policies
into real world operations and to this
end
we present what is called microsoft
airsim
and airsim is a tool that tries to
address the high fidelity
requirement in two different ways so the
first one is visual fidelity and you can
see from these pictures on the left and
the right
that airsim has a very good graphics
engine so this is because it links up to
aaa video game simulators or video game
engines we
typically mainly support unreal engine
but we also have experimental support
for unity
so you can see that the worlds are quite
realistic as compared to
real world and then we have access to
many features such as realistic lighting
high resolution textures and so on
and the advantage of all of that is that
our vision or perception pipelines are
now learning in something that is
trying to replicate real life as much as
possible in terms of visuals
and the second aspect of the fidelity is
the physical simulation of the robots
so we have these robot dynamic models in
airsim that try to approximate the
dynamics of the real robots
as much as possible and to this end we
actually have support for two different
platforms in airsim and as you can see
here we have a car
and we have a quadcopter drone so you're
allowed to kind of train policies for
either of those vehicles
while leveraging the visuals and the
physical simulation
of the robots so before we go into more
detail about airsim
let's kind of take a broad look at what
an
ai centric simulation would look like
right so let's start from the right
where we have the robot
and sensor suite so first thing we need
is as i've said before
is a physics model for the robot which
is we're trying to match the real world
physics model as much as possible
right so and then because the robots
typically sense or perceive the world
through like a fleet of sensors
we need multiple sensor modalities and
to this end airsim tries to provide for
example
um you know cameras like rgb cameras or
stereo cameras
lidars imus and so on and so forth and
now that we have all of these sensor or
robotic data we should be able to record
them
and then have them as training data for
our pipelines in machine learning so
we should be able to record these um
robot states
sensor data and the corresponding
actions as we explore the world
and while all of this is on one side of
the coin the other side is basically the
environmental part of it
so this is where the high fidelity
graphics comes into picture so we should
be able to interact with a world
that looks realistic and feels realistic
so we should have control
over the environment so for example we
want to see moving pedestrians for
instance or
whatever obstructions or you know
distractions that the real world might
have
the robot can get confused by so we can
simulate them and try to learn from them
and then finally and i want to point
this out specifically there is a feature
called domain randomization which is
very typically used in ai pipelines
this is essentially saying that whatever
my task is i want to
learn this task in many different
settings for example if i want to detect
a pedestrian
using machine learning i should be able
to detect the pedestrian no matter what
the background is
right so when i'm training my pipelines
i want to randomize the backgrounds and
the lighting conditions and the weather
conditions and so on and so forth so
this is the randomization that airsim
lets you do
so at the end of the day all of this
comes together to enable
real-world ai with simulation so to this
end we provide
you know the ability to get labeled data
for supervised learning tasks
for example you can do object detection
and segmentation
and you can also do you know robot
specific things like localization and
path planning and so on
and of course because it's a simulation
it lets you also interact with it many
many many times
through reinforcement learning so you
can have rewards and
actions basically you know driving each
other and then you can have an agent
that learns from
a realistic simulation
so just a quick uh or a you know deeper
look into the ecosystem of harrison
so airsim acts as a plug-in which is on
the right
to a game engine and then currently we
support unreal engine and unity as our
uh target platforms so the game engine
is responsible for sort of hosting the
simulation and the world
and it contains a lot of objects it's
basically a scenery that you can design
by yourself or you can get started with
some of the sample
worlds that we have available the game
engine has its own native physics which
is what most of the world operates upon
but airsim on the right has its own
custom physics that it uses for the
robots themselves so this is a little
bit more accurate
and more easier to work with for the end
user
so we can have full control on the
dynamics and things like that for the
robot
so we have the robot platforms which is
either a car or a drone
we have the ability to acquire data from
sensors and then we also let the users
send you know control or planning
commands basically through a python api
which is easy to start with
and on the top left i have a mention of
hardware in the loop or software in the
loop which is hit or sitl
so this is a concept that is very useful
for quadrotors and some of your the
drone
uh focusing people might in you might
know this uh
so there is um off-the-shelf hardware
such as the pixhawk or things like that
for drones which typically go
on the drone platforms in real life so
airsim lets us actually plug them in
as a hardware in the loop simulation or
simulate them internally
so we can have compatible performance uh
with the real drone so whatever we build
in the simulation should be able to
transfer to like a real drone platform
so in terms of the features and the api
the user can
use and control so let's go right to
left so we have the environment
where the robot lives so in the
environment we have access to a lot of
different features so for instance uh
we can change the weather effects so
we're already having a certain level of
randomization here
so we can have rain fog dust and snow
and so on and so forth
we can change the time of day and things
like that so we'll have different
lighting conditions
um there is ability to control the
existing objects in the environment
and all the information regarding them
like the poses or the sizes etc
and of course uh one of our failure
metrics is typically collisions right so
when we have a self-driving car
when it collides with something that's
that's a failure so we have the ability
to continuously record these collisions
and then whenever for example a
collision happens you can basically say
okay that's the end of that episode let
me train again
so we have that information coming from
airsim as well and for the vehicle we
have the quadcopter in the car platforms
and
we can use multi-agents of those as well
so we can have a swarm of drones or
multiple cars in in the scene
um in terms of controlling the robots we
have uh something called you know like
low level medium level and high level
control
so for the low level control we can
control motors motor speeds
angular velocities and so on and for the
medium on the high level we can do
velocity control position control
trajectory control and it's up to the
task and it's up to the user to pick
which one
is the best fit and in terms of sensors
we have a wide range of sensors that can
be simulated so we have cameras
typically so we have the rgb
this is the visual camera we have depth
cameras which give us the per-pixel
distances to the objects that we are
observing
we have a segmentation view i'll go
through some more details later
and then we also have the stereo depth
coming in from the cameras so
these cameras can also be controlled we
can control the poses
the field of view the distortion things
like that and at the same time we also
have the conventional gps imu sensors
as well as the lidars so tip so
basically the broad idea is that
we should be able to play with any kind
of sensor or vehicle parameters that we
want
and then we want to learn from these
multi-modal rich kind of sensor data and
then we want to train
robust and efficient pipelines so this
is a quick overview of what airsim
tries to do on all the access that we
have to the features
so let me talk about some sample
research projects that we have done over
the past
and then how exactly have these projects
benefited from airsim
and over the course of this i'm mostly
focusing on projects that have
uh involved drones but of course i mean
the same thing can be extended to
you know the cars or any other platform
that you would wish to simulate later
okay so let's start with a simple
perception problem so this is something
that i worked on during my phd years and
i've made heavy use affairs
in this work so the idea is to
detect and localize a drone from another
drone that has a depth camera on board
and the depth camera is essentially a
camera that gives you not only pixel
data
but on the right you can see that it has
a certain looking representation where
every pixel represents a certain
distance
so the brighter the pixel the closer it
is basically so
detecting drones through a depth camera
is very useful because now we can also
localize them with a certain distance
and we can write for example
obstacle avoidance pipelines so of
course this is not an easy problem
because drones can be of different types
the environments can be of different
types there's different kinds of
lighting
etc etc so how can we leverage a
simulation like airsim for instance to
help us with this task
so what we did was we tried to come up
with some sample
scenes in airsim and for example on the
bottom
on the left and the right here we can
see that we've generated some different
kinds of environments so we have indoor
spaces we have outdoor spaces with
random objects sitting in the
environment and all of this can be
designed by the user
right so and in here what we did was we
spawned
different drone types in airsim so the
idea was for
each of these drones or environment
types we would generate training data
that contains depth maps which people
this is the one on the middle that we
will use for the final
final testing and for each depth map
there is a corresponding segmentation
map
and then airsim provides both of those
right so this acts as a ground truth for
instance
so we can label all of these drones
according to their actual locations and
segmentation map
and then we can randomize this for
different drone types different
positions rotations
lighting and all of these can be changed
by the by the user
and we also try to inject some noise in
these images so the images
look you know kind of similar to what
you would see in a real-life stereo
camera
and then one thing i would specifically
like to point out here is that
in this application we knew that our
target drone had a certain stereo camera
so in our case it was a stereo labs zed
stereo camera
so what we were able to do in airsim was
actually replicate the exact parameters
that are used in that camera so the same
baseline
and the same field of view were used in
airsim to get as close as possible to
the target platform
so we have access to all such features
to you know train a pipeline that's as
robust as possible
so once we have this training data so we
were able to train an off-the-shelf
detection model in this case it was a
yolo detection model
and then we were able to
straightforwardly transfer this from
simulation
to real life and the randomization is
the one that helps the most and here
you can see a video of the of the target
drone that is the one that's flying here
and then there is the host drone on the
left which is trying to capture the
video and detect
so as you can see when i pause the video
you can see a bounding box that's being
drawn around the target drone so it's
able to detect
and localize it as it goes to flight
and here we also noticed that the
perception model that was trained in
simulation was able to scale up
to uh multiple drones in real life and
also different drone types that it has
not seen
so the fact that we randomized it to
some extent was helpful in the
generalization capacity so now you can
see there are multiple drones flying in
the workspace
and the host drone is able to detect
both of them
as you can see on the bottom left
so in this last test we have about three
drones actually so it's
supposed to detect all three of them and
if i pause here you can see that you
know there's a drone here there's a
drone here
and so the idea is that getting training
data from simulation is actually much
more helpful
than just trying to get data in real
life because gathering this kind of data
in real life would be quite painful
and in simulation we have the luxury of
changing so many parameters that would
be
very hard to do in real life so this
helps us create a
kind of like a robust generalizable
model
so this is a classic perception sort of
a problem that was solved through the
use of deep learning
so now let's look at the action part of
it so what if i wanted to take actions
and i wanted to train this uh a drone in
simulation
so this was work that was done by uh
researchers over at carnegie mellon
university
and then the idea driving this work is
actually quite fun so the question is
can a drone act as an aerial
cinematographer so if i have a test
subject
as you can see on the top top here
so there's a test subject that is
walking in a scene
and the drone is the one that's flying
around and taking pictures
can i come up with a pipeline that lets
the drone do this in a smarter fashion
so can you understand what does a good
shot mean like what is
an artistic shot look like right so what
they tried to do
was they tried to use model free methods
and specifically reinforcement learning
to learn policies that will move the
drone in a certain way that the shots
look good
and for this because you know you could
have a variety of test subjects in
variety of environments
and all those things so again they try
to leverage airsim
as a possible tool for simulation so
they designed
a like many different kinds of
environments in airsoft as you can see
from left to right so it starts with a
very simple environment with just a few
blocks
a slightly more complex environment with
some obstacles and then on the right you
have a realistic looking scene with a
test subject and all three of them just
walking around
so what they did here was they were able
to quickly prototype many kinds of
rewards for reinforcement learning
and some of these were human like
handcrafted rewards
some of these rewards were based on just
exploration some city awards were based
on feedback from other people
things like that so the fact that all of
this was spun up in simulation makes it
really easy to run through many
different kinds of
approaches and then pick the best
working one and the fact that they have
different environments also makes your
policy robust
to you know changes or just animation
changes or
just changing the environment and
obstacles and things like that so
here's a quick example of how that looks
like so you can see that they were able
to simulate
movement of for example a person in a
realistic looking scene and they were
able to
go through various kinds of trajectories
that are part of the oral training
so this lets us prototype you know many
different test cases
and kind of find this policy that's
robust enough so the fact that all of
this was you know high fidelity enough
was enough to allow them to kind of
deploy this
in a real-life drone so they were able
to train an agent in simulation
and then put it in a real-life pipeline
so as you can see from this picture
the drone becomes the director as the
video says and it has learned only in
simulation
but it learns you know tries to capture
what does an aesthetic shot look like
and then tries to do the same thing
so here you can see it's able to adapt
to certain obstacles in the environment
moves to you know desirable locations
not hit the trees and so on
yep so essentially what's happening here
is the decision-making aspect of it or
like
what action should i take is being dealt
with by a data-driven reinforcement
learning pipeline
um but i have to note here that most of
the rest of the things like tracking the
person or planning et cetera are being
done in a classical fashion so the
reinforcement learning is mainly
for the decision making for the shot
selection but now it raises an
interesting question
so can i do everything in a data-driven
fashion can i do perception and action
like i mentioned in the beginning of
this talk
can i bring them both together using
data-driven methods and how does the
simulation work for that
so here let's talk about a more
interesting question
so on the left i'm showing you a
simulation scene where
a drone is trying to fly through a bunch
of square gates right
if i wanted to learn a policy in
simulation you know looking at this
environment
and then put it in real life as shown in
the right what would i have to do
right so what is a representation that
lets me go from simulation to reality
in the most efficient way and this is
work that's been done internally at
microsoft
and the the paper and the code are
actually available open sourced
so i'll point you to some links at the
end of this talk so
now the question is i need to do both
perception and action
learning from a simulation so here we
have we can break this down into two
parts right so for example if the task
is to look at this image the one shown
on the left there is a red gate over
there
and i want to go through that gate which
is the task right so
the first part would be to extract the
position or the pose of the gate so i
need to know you know where to go
and then i would have to compute the
control action that will actually take
me there
and the first part which is the post
pose extraction needs to be robust to
changes because
even if there is a different background
for example in the previous slide we saw
that those two scenes are completely
different
right so there's different textures
different everything except for the fact
that there's a red gate
so whatever perception pipeline that i
learned has to be robust to such things
and then the compute the control action
that's being computed once i know the
pose needs to be you know optimal and
fast enough because it's a drone and we
want to do it
in a smooth fast fashion so
this work proposes using what's called a
cross modal variational auto
a variational autoencoder is generative
model which basically tries to learn
a compressed representation of any given
image right so in this task what this
work tries to do
is it tries to enforce the constraint
that you know the gate is the only
important part of my image right
so i don't really care what the
background looks like as long as i can
infer the position of the gate from from
a given image
so what's happening here is that they're
leveraging airsim
to generate a lot of training data for
these for these gates so as you can see
for example
in the graphic here in the middle so a
drone is being made to fly
through a bunch of gates and then all of
those images are being recorded
and then they train a cross model
variational auto encoder to compress
this image
so what's happening here is that it
tries to learn a condensed
representation
along with learning the pose of the gate
so now it knows
what for example a given picture
corresponds to in terms of the pose
right okay so now that i know the pose
how do i learn actions right and of
course we can always do reinforcement
learning which is just exploding
randomly but it's not
very sample efficient if you think about
it because the robot is going to need to
go through many many many trials just to
understand that
going forward is the right action for
instance so to make things a little bit
more efficient the authors propose the
use of what's called limitation learning
so here again we leverage airsim to
provide us with what we call expert
actions
so we can have a controller in built to
air sim that is
you know made to fly through all of
these gates continuously
right so for every image that we capture
of this gate we can also have an
associated control action that's being
done by the expert
so now we train a behavior cloning or
any imitation learning pipeline to learn
from these actions so now we have
very extensive training data right so we
are capturing data for the perception
as well as the action and then we train
this uh you know in like a two-phase
fashion
so just to recap what did airsim do here
so airsim was providing training data of
the images of the drone gates which is
trivial
and then the poses of all the drone
gates because in a simulation you know
exactly what every object is right so if
you're looking at an object you know
where the pose really is
and then also the expert trajectories
from a high level controller
that is inbuilt to airsim so airsim is
able to provide all the data for the
agent to learn from so in the paper and
for more details you can look at the
paper itself
they use the variation of encoder
coupled with a behavior cloning pipeline
for the
agent to learn so on the right you can
actually see
graphics of it working in real life when
it was entirely trained only in
simulation so no real-life data was used
and the fact that it is a you know it's
a variation auto encoder that tries to
compress the image
so on the bottom here uh you can see
that all of these images that are being
seen
are actually being converted to a
representation that was learned in
simulation
so you can kind of uh compare the
previous
you know the grassy environment in air
sim that's still visible here
so all the real images are being
understood by the agent in a simulation
point of view
and it's still able to take the right
actions so even on the top you can see
it's a very challenging environment with
you know snow
and reflections on the ground and yet
the drone is able to use the
you know model trained in simulation and
transferred to real life
so the recap of these projects is
basically to say that airsim
has been quite effective in helping some
research projects and there is a more
extensive list of projects on our
website
um so you can you can go through that
and then get ideas and how you can use
airsim as well
but this project typically i mean i'm
gonna emphasize this one a little bit
more
because the pro the problem we're facing
here the idea of drones going through
these gates
is actually a very interesting research
problem today
so we can think of it as a new research
direction essentially and this is
something interesting because it's being
driven by a concept that came out of
you know hobby drone racers so drone
racing is actually as you can see in the
video here it's a pretty popular sport
today
so there is something called the drone
racing league which hosts um
competitions internationally
with uh you know huge amounts of prize
money and so on very famous
very popular and looking at these you
know people flying the drones the
research community obviously had the
question like can we actually have a
drone do these
insanely complex maneuvers right what
does it take to have an autonomous drone
you know fly through these gates and in
a
you know in like a very fast or very
aggressive uh kind of a flight
so the new research direction now is can
we have autonomous drone racing
and what you know what does an agent
that is trying to do atmosphere racing
look like and what kind of
capabilities do we need to train
something like that
so the specific reason why autonomous
drone racing is really interesting
is it brings together a perception
planning and control
so the perception is obviously quite
complex because now we're
focusing on such a small sparse part of
the environment all we care about is the
locations of the gates and that we have
to go through
them and the planning and control are
also very complicated because now we are
supposed to
move at very high speeds and do you know
task specific sensing
uh you know just focusing on the gates
for example and all these maneuvers
and the other thing is the game
theoretic aspect because here you're
supposed to win a race
it's not enough to just fly through the
gates but you have to do it you know as
fast as possible
so here we are combining you know safe
and robust autonomy with sort of like
aggressive actions and game theoretic
planning
so over the last couple of years there
have been many competitions actually
focusing
on this particular research problem and
one of them was microsoft's own
game of drones competition that we
co-hosted from our group
at europe's 2019 so at the same time
there was a
pretty popular competition called the
lockheed martin alpha pilot which
also wanted the competitors to build an
autonomous racing drone
and then there is a regular yearly
contest that happens at the intelligent
robots and systems conference which is
focused on drone racing as well and
looking at this newfound interest in
drone racing
our group has come up with an
enhancement for airsim that is focused
on drone racing
so we call this the airsim drone racing
lab so essentially what's happening here
is that we take airsim
and then we give it some extra
capabilities that are focused towards
drone racing so now we have
trajectory planners that let you
actually go through uh you know
waypoints in space and this was actually
what was used in the work uh with the
vae
and then we have controllers that can do
smooth fast actions given trajectories
the users can actually generate or use
existing race tracks with a bunch of
gates
and we also have a lot of racing logic
right so for example you can have lap
times
you can have disqualification metrics
for example if you hit a gate or if you
get ahead of drone you get disqualified
you know you can log your progress you
can record all the states and actions
so now it lets you actually train these
pipelines
that are focused on fast aggressive
autonomy that is that is useful for
drone racing
and just a just another quick addition
to that is that we are also this is an
active development so we are also going
to add more features in the near future
so what we are planning to add are
things like you know mapping pipelines
for instance so we would have
an estimate of occupancy in the maps for
example if you're going through gates
you need to know that the gate is an
obstacle and that should be avoided
right so we need like an occupancy map
for instance
there's also more robotic specific tools
like sign distance fields which allow
you to do efficient mapping and
avoidance
um the domain randomization factors in
again because
you know we want to be able to train
these pipelines to look at not just one
color or one configuration of gates but
any kind of gate needs to be understood
as something to go through
right so there is domain randomization
here um we have the same
uh you know sensor pipelines essentially
so we have rgb
depth segmentation but we are also
adding some new novel sensors like
neuromorphic cameras
neuromorphic cameras are quite
interesting because they stream
uh not you know frames but they stream
events at
a very very high rate like even up to
megahertz worth of updates which lets
you take aggressive and fast actions and
so on
so all of these are in the works and
then airsim drone racing lab is an
active development
and yeah we hope that this would be of
good use to researchers
and actually at the end of this webinar
i'm going to use an initial version of
here some drone racing lab for a quick
demo of the features
so here are some links as to where
airsim can be found and all the
documentation for airsim
and also airsome drone racing lab uh as
i mentioned the work that just done with
vae and imitation learning for drone
navigation it's open sourced under
microsoft so please
go take a look at that and then if you
need more information on the game of
drones competition there's a website for
that as well
and now i'm going to move to a quick
demo of the airsim features
okay so in the demo part of things on
the top left you actually have a view of
harrison and this is the airsim drone
racing lab so you can actually
see uh sort of like a race track of
gates right so there's a circular race
track here
and in airsim if you press f1 you get a
list of all the options you can play
with for example there are
different camera views we can go over
and different camera windows that we can
use for sensor visualizations
so on the bottom here there is three
windows sub-windows
on the left we have a depth view and on
the middle we have a segmentation so you
can see all the objects have a specific
segmentation mask right on the right you
have the typical rgb sort of a
visualization from onboard the drone so
the drone has all these cameras on board
in a similar fashion
so let's try to you know maybe do
something simple
so what i'm going to do first is i'm
going to initialize what's called a
multirotor client so this gives us
access
to all the drone specific functions
right so i'm going to
do that and then i'm going to request to
have control of the drone from the
python side of things so this is all
happening in python right now
so now that i have access by running
enable api control
i'm going to try to do the simplest
operation which is take off
and the reason i say async is because
it's an asynchronous operation that
gives me control back
one side on the command as you can see
the drone is taking
off it's flying up to a specified
altitude
and then now we can send some arbitrary
control command so for instance
let's say i want to move forwards with
the velocity of
5 meters per second for five seconds so
i'm gonna say
move by velocity async again i'm gonna
say five meters per second and the x and
x is forward in this
coordinate frame and zero on the other
two axes and i'm gonna do it for
five seconds so the duration is the last
parameter so
and then you can see the drone flying
forwards for about five seconds
so this is a medium level control right
so this is velocity control which is
you know not the lowest level we can
also move to
for example certain positions in the
world so for example i want to go to
some arbitrary position
10 10 minus 10 and then i want to use a
velocity of
2 meters per second and the reason it's
minus 10 is because it's in any d
coordinate frame so
upwards is negative so now it goes to a
pre-specified position
so anyway this this gives you an idea of
basically some of the
common control commands that we can use
and you can think of these all of these
as actions essentially right so if
you're training a policy to do
reinforcement learning or something
maybe your actions are discrete right so
you can say move left move right move
forward those are three actions so you
can have
a velocity command of minus one plus one
or something like that for your
different actions
so let's go down to like something more
reasonable here
okay so let's take a look at some of the
image pipelines right so for instance
um in one of the projects i mentioned
before there was this drone detection
project right
and in that project what we have is we
are trying to generate ground truth for
detecting
an object of interest which in that case
was a drone right and in the drone
racing lab
maybe we want to detect gates for
instance so what i'm going to do
is i want to generate ground truth
segmentation for these gates so for
example if i have a gate
that i need to you know observe i want
the segmentation map to only point
out the gate so i can use that as my
ground truth so what i'm going to do now
is let's take a look at the middle sub
window which is segmentation
and i am going to set
rotation so i'm going to set all the
objects in the scene
to the same segmentation id
so let's see how that looks
i'm just going to i'm going to explain
what this command does okay so what's
happening here is that i'm taking
all the objects in the scene which is
just using a wildcard set of character
and then i'm setting that to a specific
value and this ranges from 0 to 255 for
various colors so i'm just picking a
random color
and all of the objects in the scene are
now basically the same color
right so there's nothing there but now
what i want to do is i want to focus on
for example a specific object of
interest which is a gate so the first
thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to use a command sim list
scene objects
that gives me the list of all the
objects in the scene so these are all
the objects are present
so if you scroll up and down you can see
many many things so you can have you
know all the signposts
or there is a volleyball net i'm not
sure exactly what it is but it's
somewhere
um but here we see the drone gates right
so we have gate zero gate one gate two
get three four so on so forth
let's pick a random gate let's pick uh i
don't know gate seven
so let's try that um i'm gonna use a
function that's called sim get
object pose so what this does is for an
object of interest that i'm
gonna name by the string it's going to
give me the pose of that in real world
so i'm going to say
gate 0 6.
so now we have a pose which is a
combination of orientation and the
position so we know exactly
where this particular gate is sitting so
what i'm going to do now is let's try
moving that object let's read the object
suppose again
sim get object pose
0 6 and what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to try to change the positions x
value
slightly so let's you know add 10 to it
and then now i've changed it slightly
and i have to command that into the
simulation so now i'm going to use the
corresponding
sim set object pose i'm going to refer
to the same gate again
and then i'm gonna say okay move to this
place so if you keep an eye on the
simulation
you'll see the drone gate has moved by a
certain amount right so and then
i can sort of repeat that to just move
the gate back and forth so if i decrease
it
i can use the same command to bring it
back in again so
now that i've kind of made all this
objects the same in a segmentation map
let's focus on that particular gate and
then let's see if we can just get the
ground truth for that in the pixel space
right
so previously i used this command called
sim segmentation object id
right so now i'm going to get a little
bit more specific in here i'm going to
point to gate
6 and i want to use a different color
for that so i'm going to just randomly
pick 50.
so now in the segmentation map here
you've seen that that gate
is actually the only one that's showing
up so you can use that
as a reference as to compare you know
the rgb inputs to segmentation inputs
and that acts as your ground truth and
this is essentially what we did for the
for the tone detection project
for the training data so let's try
something else
i can also get the position
of the robot at any given time so i'm
going to say sim get
vehicle pose so that gives me a pose
so now i'm going to move the drone
sorry move the move the gate gate 0 6 to
where the drone
is currently sitting so now okay
so it's essentially blocking the drone
but
you can see that it's basically moved
over here so for example
to get training data of the gate all you
would have to do is have the drone at a
certain point
and then just keep spawning the gate in
front of the drone you know in multiple
configurations like rotations or
something like that
and then you keep capturing data as we
go so this is a very simple
uh kind of an approach that you can do
for training data
acquisition and another thing i want to
quickly point out
is we can also
change certain parameters such as the
weather in the scene so for instance if
we press f10 in airsim we actually come
across a menu
that shows us weather options we can
move the sliders around and then we can
have different kinds of weather options
so for example
if i move the snow slider i'll have a
simulation of snow
and of course the same thing for dust
fog
things like that so we can change the
scene you know as much as possible and
you can see all the
the rgb view is also you know
replicating exactly what you see in the
scene
so when we don't need it we can just
disable the weather by
unchecking this box and it clears up
so these are some simple things you can
play with and of course there's an
extensive list of api
on the airsim website so feel free to go
look at the documentation look at all
the examples that we have
and in terms of drone racing i just want
to focus on one particular example here
so here is an example script and then
let's take a look at this and see how it
works with the sim
so in the airsim drone racing lab repo
we have an example script called
baseline racer
and what i'm showing you right now is a
slightly modified version of that
so what we are trying to achieve here is
one task which is
um given a map with a bunch of gates in
it like we've seen before
in the game i wanted the drone to fly
through all of those gates essentially
so that's pretty much it
so let's take a look at the individual
steps that are required to make this
happen
so the script actually has a bunch of
input arguments that we can pass
so for example we can pass the level
name which is basically the name of the
map
and air syndrome racing lab repo has
access to multiple of these maps with
different tracks
um a couple of other interesting ones or
you can choose to enable
visualization of the trajectory of the
drone and also
visualize the image that the drone is
capturing through an opencv window and
so on and so forth
so in the main function the first thing
that i do is i'm kind of constructing an
object that's called baseline racer with
a drone name and some of the arguments
we've seen before
and i'm going to load the level which is
also straightforward all of this is
being done by like background helper
functions which are not super relevant
right now
and then i'm going to initialize the
drone and then if we take a look at the
initialize function
this is basically going through the same
pipeline that we've seen already so
we're doing enable api control that
gives the you know the python script
access to the api of the drone
we make sure it's armed and then one
thing we do here
is that we're setting um pid gains for
the trajectory tracking actually
so by the function set trajectory
tracker gains the user can choose to
have
different values of the pid gains and
these will make the drone um you know
as aggressive as possible or as sluggish
as possible depending on what
what flight characteristics that the
user needs
and all the way to the bottom again in
the main function the next thing we do
is we take off and i'm going to explain
what the move on spline
part is so if you think about the task
that is going through all of these gates
uh this one assumption i'm making in the
script
is that i know or i have access to the
ground with poses of the gates so
of course in real life you're trying to
build a racing drone it's very likely
you would have to rely on perception to
get you those poses
but for the sake of simplicity i'm just
going to assume that we have actual
poses
so if we go take a look at this function
that is get ground truth poses
you can see that it's sort of like a mix
of what we've seen earlier on the
terminal
so the first thing i'm doing is i'm
trying to get the
get the names of all the gates in the
map by looking at the output of simless
scene objects so if you remember we
leveraged two functions before
for the testing uh one of them was
similarly seen objects and the other one
was sim get object post and then we're
going to make use of them again here
so i'm going to look at all the objects
that have the word gate in them
so that gives me a list of all the gate
names i'm doing
a couple of little cleanup operations
here on the strings
and then eventually what i'm doing is
for each of those gates in the list of
names
i'm going to run sim get object pose and
then that's going to give me the pose of
that gate and i'm going to keep track of
all of them by putting them in a little
list
so at the end of this function what i do
have is like the ground truth poses of
all the gates
in a list so these gate poses or
whatever
that we just accessed they are supposed
to act as you know intermediate
waypoints for the trajectory planner so
the trajectory should be constructed
going through these waypoints and then
kind of that will basically become a
loop that the drone will follow through
all the gates
before i start flying to the gates i
just want to point out one quick thing
i'm doing here as well
this is how we can record imagery from
the drone or any other drone state data
so i'm spawning two callbacks here and
then i'm just gonna go directly to the
main function of the callback
so we have two particular callbacks one
of them is an image callback and one of
them is an odometry callback
in the image callback i am making use of
the airsim api
function called sim get images and sim
get images typically requires a request
and here if you can see line 109
we can see that the request that we are
asking for is that of an image type
scene
and this is basically the rgb image we
can also change this to depth
segmentation disparity you know
depending on what the user wants so we
are requesting a scene image an rgb
image
we are doing a little bit of reshaping
operations on that and finally if the
visualization argument was true
we will go ahead and display this as an
opencv window and
in the odometry callback we are making
use of another api function that's
called get multi-order state
so this will give us information about
the drone's own state at any
possible time right so we can get access
to the positions the orientation
linear velocity angular velocity also
the accelerations but
i don't have those lines out here right
now so
these two callbacks are basically an
example of how you can get other
training data right so you can record
images as the drone is going through its
trajectory
you can record its own states to get
some understanding of the dynamics or
something like that
so i'm going to spawn those callbacks
and finally the most important function
that we have here
is called fly through all gates and
let's go take a look at that
so in flight through all gates i'm
calling a function called move on spline
async
so move on spline is the back end that
we have in airsim
that takes care of both trajectory
construction that's path planning
and also trajectory tracking which is
control so the main argument for this
function is just a list of waypoints
that it's supposed to connect
so once i pass like all these gate poses
or the centers of all the gates in the
map
um the back end in airsim what it does
it's basically trying to construct a
smooth
minimum jerk trajectory that the drone
can follow and then it constructs this
trajectory and then there's a controller
that spins up in the background
and then makes the drone go through all
of the gates we can also
specify like a maximum velocity and
maximum acceleration which
are basically being set to some
arbitrary values right now but of course
you're
you can play with those values and
increase or decrease them as needed
so finally i'm going to run this
function and once it's done
because i have a join here to wait for
the function to finish
once it's done i can basically stop the
image callbacks and end
this whole script so let's go take a
look at how this would work once i run
it in the sim
so let's try to run this piece of code
so now you can see that there is a
yellow trajectory that's basically
showing that the drone is going through
um you know all the gates
so of course all the all the parameters
such as you know the maximum velocities
maximum accelerations
and even the pid gains because the drone
essentially works using a pid controller
so all of these things can be changed
through airsome api so we can make the
drone as aggressive or
as sluggish as we want it one important
thing to note is that
the trajectory that's being drawn as a
yellow line is actually visible in the
images down below
so for actual training data we want to
remove that
by passing a parameter that controls the
visualization
of the trajectory itself
and airsim ground racing lab comes with
these baseline scripts so you can get
started with
you know these spline planners and
any kind of like data recording or
little logging kind of features
so yeah now it's basically completed
like full loop and it's back
you know it's at the end of the gate so
we've just what we've done now
is we tried to come up with a trajectory
planning scheme that tries to fit a
trajectory through all the gates
and then we asked the drone to go
through all of them and then at the same
time we were recording the images
and we were recording the data as you
can you saw in the script
so now because we were talking about
drone racing let's have
two drones right essentially that's
basically what erases
so what i'm going to do here is in the
baselines that we have a drone racing
lab we also provide a helper script
that is you can run it as it's called
generate settings file so this script
basically ensures that airsim knows
there are two drones
so here we see a sample settings file
that was generated by the script i just
ran before
so what's happening here is i have a tab
called vehicles and then vehicles
contains the configuration
for two drones now so you can see drone
one and on the bottom you see drone two
so each of these uh tabs basically has
information on
for example the pose of the robot in the
beginning right so you can have x y z
roll pitch yaw settings that are the
initial positions orientations
same thing for drone 2. and for each
drone we can also set specific camera
settings so
right now we're only doing it for drone
one because that is the only one that's
being controlled by the user
and the other one is like an internal
air sim control drone
so for this we can name a camera with
some arbitrary name we're calling it
fpvcam
we can set the field of view which is 90
degrees right now and we can set the
height and the width
right now the resolution is 320 by 240
and that can be changed to anything
and all of this data like the you know
the field of view
or the orientation of the camera or you
know the position of the camera they can
all be changed
through the airsim api itself so now
that we have the settings file let's uh
go ahead and try to actually run a race
with two drones
so here i am going to run
the baseline razer script which is in
the examples
but with a specific flag here so that is
enable
this image cv2 what it does is now it's
trying to show me
the onboard video of the drone so i
should have access to like an opencv
window of what the front-facing camera
is looking at
so once i run this so the ram is going
to restart
and then again you can see the objects
over here we can see the front-facing
camera on the right
and in the game over the top left we see
a
kind of like a race metrics sort of a
visualization so we have access to
the race time uh we can see metrics like
how many gates has a drone passed and
drone one drone two separately
um so basically what's happening here is
that we are using the same technique i
described before of like trying to fit a
spline
and then going through all the gates but
now we are looking at from a race
perspective so we are trying to
uh fly with respect to the other drone
right sound looks like we're winning so
far okay so this is how you basically
can
set up an example race and then use it
to get some training data so from this
point of view
you can get training data for the
perception like you're seeing on the
right from the opencv window
you can get data about the actions and
the odometry itself
and you can get data with respect to the
other drone right so maybe if you're
losing you can learn from the other
drone's actions to get better and better
so this lets you train your agents for
many many different tasks
so this is kind of like a quick overview
of what airsim drone racing lab tries to
do so it sets you up in this racing
environment
where you still have access to most of
the airsome api but slightly
enhanced with this concept of autonomous
drone racing so now you can train
agents that are not only just doing
perception action loops but
they probably are doing it in a
competitive fashion so now you can
actually try to you know beat the other
drones or
you know hopefully be a human racer in
the end so that was a quick demo of what
airsome drone racing lab can do and how
you can sort of get started with you
know sample
autonomous racing drones right um so
these are all the links that might be
useful and you can also find these in
the resource list on the platform
and we have links to airsim airsim drone
racing lab itself
and some of the work on the vae and
imitation learning is open sourced
so you can access the code for that and
data sets and also please check out
the microsoft game of drones website
which has a lot of info on how we hosted
the previous competition and hopefully
there'll be more to come so
yeah that's it for this talk thank you
so much for listening
and i'd be happy to take any more
questions in the live q a that's going
to quickly follow
hi everyone this is sai van perala
thanks for attending the
harnessing hypothetical simulations for
robotics seminar
and this is the live q a session and
over the next 15 minutes
i'd like to answer some of the top
questions submitted by the audience also
some of the
questions that we typically get about
garrison in training ai models for
robotics in general
so okay so the first question i wanted
to tackle
and this is something that we have uh
we've gotten
quite often is how do we change the
parameters of the drone
right for instance you might have seen
like we have a simple flight
which is a very simple drone platform
right so
if you wanted to you know simulate a
different kind of drone or maybe
simulate different kinds of physics
for instance what you can do is it is
possible to go into the source code
which is on the
on the github repository and um
so one of the one of the parts of the
source code is what we call
the air lib which is the main folder and
then air lib contains
vehicles and multi-rotor and inside the
multi-order part of air lib what we have
is you know a list of parameters that
simulate the drone itself so you have
things like the mass of the drone
uh things like the dimensions for
example the on light um you know other
kinds of parameters like the
propeller dynamics and stuff like that
so you can always
you know go ahead and change those
inside the source code and then when you
simulate airsim again
you would you should see like a
different different kind of physics
simulation and the other
question that i got from the q a was
does the camera support distortion
models and
yes this is something that we have on
the road map as of now
and it's not part of the actual airsome
code but it will soon be part of
the airsim drone racing lab repository
so please keep an eye on both of those
because
the drone racing lab one is under active
development and we are definitely adding
a lot of features there
um another question that i saw in the q
a was can we directly capture fisheye
images
using airsim and a fisheye image is
technically like a you know a special
case of a different field of view right
so it is definitely possible to
um you know increase the field of view
in the settings itself so the default is
typically 90 degrees but you can always
go over that maybe like you know 150 160
degrees which is getting closer to
fisheye but if you also want to get like
the distorted effect
it goes back to my uh my previous answer
so this is something that we are trying
to implement
and then soon we will have a distortion
model and as well as you know changing
field of view
and one other question i got was how was
the drone racing lab created and
you know what was the effort that took
so the drone racing lab itself
is a collaboration between microsoft
research our team and
stanford university and university of
zurich
so this was something that spun up as an
idea for the game of drones competition
so as part of you know the idea of game
of drones we wanted to focus
solely on the simulation of of racing
grounds because you know
building a racing drone in hardware is
typically hard so
as part of that we spend a few months
about three or four months just you know
coming up with enhancements to airsome
and um so you can see like the v1 of
this at the air syndrome racing lab repo
and then in the future we want to add a
lot more features that are contributing
towards robot autonomy
so we are looking at uh features that
will help with you know mapping of
environments and
planning and collision avoidance because
that's also a big deal when you're
flying really fast and also at the same
time you're adding other features which
will help perception such as you know
changing distortion models and
you know we're also looking into the
idea of having event-based cameras for
those of you who might
heard about them so we are looking into
many new center models and things like
that so please keep an eye on the drum
racing lab for more
updates in the future and um
okay so another question that i got was
are you able to model energy using
airsim and this is a great question
because you know the performance of
drones is very
very much tightly coupled with the
performance of the battery itself
so this is not something that we have
out of the box in airsim but there is
actually
a couple of features that have been
contributed by the community so
um you might you may have seen my answer
in the
in the audience q a so please feel free
to visit the repo and then if you look
for
like battery simulation or just battery
in the issues and the pull requests you
can actually
find some forks affairs in which have
tried to simulate
uh battery capacity and how it changes
over over
over a flight so this is something that
is not officially a feature but it has
been added by other people
so you can go ahead and use that and
that's the great thing about open source
right because you know
you get contributions from many
different many different community
members
and in other question that i have was
about how close is this to the typical
you know the gym open ai gym kind of a
framework
so so what we have in airsyn
is typically uh we have access to two
kinds of clocks so we have something
called a settable clock and then we have
something called a scalable clock
so the scalable clock is something that
lets you simulate faster than real time
or slower you know
depending on what you wish and the
steppable clock is something
that will allow you to sort of you know
pause and continue the simulation
this is something that is getting you
closer to like a typical auto kind of
paradigm
so although we don't have full parity
with the open ai gym framework itself
it is possible for you to utilize these
features and then write your own like
you know
pause and continue sort of an api and in
the future for airstream drone racing
lab we would like to actually
bring in full parity with like a gym
specific kind of an api so you know it's
easier to train auto
algorithms and another great question i
just received
was how would you tackle learning safety
in a drone flying in a simulation
and this is you know as i mentioned in
the earlier portions of my talk
this is a big focus for us at the
autonomous systems group right because
safety is paramount so the way we look
at it is for instance
when i talked about air syndrome racing
lab and i said that okay we're going to
look at features for mapping and
planning
so mapping is typically the one thing
that helps you the most with safety
right because it tells you where the
obstacles are
it tells you what they might look like
and one feature we are trying to add
and which will soon be a part of the
drone racing lab is
uh what we call fine distance field so
this is something that is very widely
used in literature
so a sign distance field typically is
like an occupancy grid but with
you know with an estimate of how far you
are from the closest obstacle
by using features like this you can
learn you know really safe operations
so you can know what policy would keep
me you know as safe as possible given a
bunch of obstacles or given other drones
flying in the environment so
these are these are features that we
want to add to help with research that
is specifically focused on
focused on safety and
another question was other than carson
drones are there hopes for different
modes
so this would be you know things like
boats or two-wheel vehicles or different
physics and physics
models again this is uh of definite
interest to a lot of people because
robotics is such a wide array of you
know vehicles
um as of now we are mainly focusing on
cars and drones but because this is open
source
and because you have access to unreal
engine which is you know a very um
typical uh game engine right so you do
have the luxury to go and create many
different kinds of many different kinds
of robots
and also leverage some of the ue physics
which is coming from unreal engine
but there's one thing i would also like
to note is apart from cars and drones we
do have a mode that we call
the computer vision mode so what happens
in the computer vision mode is that
we just take the robot away so there is
only a floating camera if you think
about it
so there is no robot physics there is
just a camera that you can move around
and then so this is for people who don't
really want to deal with dynamics so if
you just want to grab some data from the
environment
all you need is like a bunch of images
you know you know feel free to just run
it in computer vision mode and you can
see
more um you know more details about this
on the repo itself if you look for
computer vision
and okay so another another good
question that we get
pretty often is like can we run this in
a headless mode and the answer is yes
so uh the headless mode typically
involves you know off-screen rendering
right so you're not actually rendering
it on the screen because maybe you're
running in the docker image where you
don't care
about you know rendering the actual game
itself so if you go in the repo and then
you look for the instructions on how to
run docker images they should they
should give you an answer
about how to run this in headless and
another
recent question was is airsoft
integrated into ross and yes
gladly the answer is yes so again in if
you go to the repository and you look
for ros we do have an airsim ross
wrapper
so this this will you know basically
take in all the data that airsome is
publishing in terms of
positions velocities images etc and then
just pushes them out as ros topics
so you know please go take a look at the
functionality there and if you have
any more questions you know i can always
for all of you basically please feel
free to open up issues on the airs and
github itself so we can have
more discussion
and yes another question was if i want
to capture imu data at a specific
location of the drone
and have the corresponding images how do
we do that so this
is basically very similar to what we
tried in the airsim drone racing lab
demo
right so we have the move on spline
function and then you can have a
callback which is essentially
getting you an image and then you can
sort of you know
if you have worked with ross you would
know how the approximate time sync and
things like that work so you could
basically have a callback that gets the
image
and then right at the same time tries to
get the imu data as well
uh so we have functions that access the
imu data through you know the apis that
things like get ground troop kinematics
et cetera which are
kind of uh the accelerations and the
gyroscopic velocities and stuff like
that
so yes it is possible to do it you just
have to access the right functions at
the callback
you know and then you can have this
callback spinning in the background
right
another question was well the second
drone always lose no it's not
so so the second drone if it's your
drone you know
uh it is definitely possible to
understand the the dynamics of the first
drone right and then you should try
to you know come up with comfort
strategies to try to be it so this is
where
it's a it's a really game theory to kind
of a question and that's why drone
racing is exciting
it's not just about perception and
planning it's also about
you know taking advantage and having
have like adversarial
sort of strategies to let you in the
game
and is there a way to treat a game
window as a video stream
instead of collecting single images
through image requests this is a great
question because it gives you
a higher frequency of data and yes the
answer is yes
all you would have to do is you can
switch to a
first person view for the drone for
example if you're flying the drone in ue
and like you saw in the demo you
typically have like a third person view
but if you press f
you can actually go to first person view
and then it's definitely possible to you
know
use obs or any of the streaming
recording softwares to just record the
video
so now you have like a high frequency
video directly from the game
and in terms of this question that i
just got about do you have any chat
channel where we can ask questions and
get support again
the issues tab in the github repository
is the best place to get in touch with
us and you can also
get help from a lot of the community
because it's a very active community on
github they've got about 10 000 stars
already so
uh for people who have already been
supporting us thanks a lot and then this
is a very active community so please uh
if you have any questions feel free to
open up an issue
or submit any prs if you have any
features you want to see
in airsome is there support to run
multiple instances of the simulation so
this is a good question
the answer is sort of like yes and no
because yes you can run multiple
instances of the simulation
but what you would have to do is make
sure that the api endpoints are all
different
right so you would have to spawn
different clients and then also make
sure the servers are all on different
ports so you can you know send commands
independently to all of these all these
instances and
one thing to note is also the fact that
you know it's
sort of gpu heavy like pearson because
of its realism coming from unreal engine
it's a little bit intensive on the gpu
so i would you know if you're trying to
look for multiple instances of the
simulation you would either have to run
this
on azure on like a cluster or you would
probably have to use multiple gpus
and another question was can we model
air or
wind so this is not something that we
have
out of the box what we have for wind in
the weather effects is only a visual
effect so it
just shows you um you know the weather
particles are moving in different
directions based on the wind vector
but using unreal engines features
because you know it's open source and
you can just literally
download the source code and open up
open it up as a ue game
it is possible to actually have wind
vectors that will that will affect the
physics
but this is something that you you know
you would have to work on
um another very recent question was
there does airstream use the gpu in
headless mode
um yes because you would still if you
still want to have
um you know first person camera images
and things like that it would still need
a gpu to render them the only thing that
would
that would be gone is like the uh the
main game window itself
but there is another version of headless
mode which is like no
render essentially so we just disable
all of the rendering and you just set
the physics simulation
and also documentation for this is again
on the on the github repository
another recent question was can airsim
tell us about the mechanics and the
forces acting on the drone also can the
user manually give instructions that is
data to train the model
this is not something that we have
exposed so the api that we have exposed
are sort of
the lowest level you can go to is
setting the motor pwms so you can just
send like motor commands
but um if you look at you know as i
mentioned before in the q a i talked
about simple flight and how you can find
the parameters for that
so if you go look at that portion of the
code and you try to kind of
understand how the api generally works
it is possible to
expose those parts of the code to the
api so you can probably just send
you know body forces or body moments
like you know fx
f z or things like that so that would
actually be direct forces on the drone
itself or you can set the
forces from the from the propellers the
rotors themselves
so it is possible to extend the existing
api but we don't
have it out of the box
and a couple of other questions that we
typically get are basically you know
different sensor models
right so people have asked us about
thermal cameras
or you know even based cameras like i
mentioned before so
we do have apart from you know rgb
depth and segmentation we also have what
we call like a mock
infrared mode so this is trying to
simulate what a thermal camera would see
but i just want to note that this is not
like a fully accurate infrared camera
simulation but this is more of like
you know similar to segmentation certain
object material types would have certain
temperatures you know just like an
approximate estimate so
there is actually a very interesting
project that has used airsim for
detecting wildlife
in african forests so if you go on the
airsim github repo you can actually find
some details about this and there is
also
an example environment that you know
sort of puts you in this nice beautiful
african wildlife expanse
and that actually has a simulation of of
infrared cameras so that's
something you can play with
and cool and then the question was what
are the sensors that can be integrated
support for rgbd
and rgbd is sort of already there
because you do have rgb and you do have
depth
and for the depth we have different
kinds of depth as well so we have
perspective depth in our depth etc
so it's possible to just you know kind
of if you're if you're using the ros
interface for instance you just pull in
images from
the rgb topic and then the depth topic
and then that sort of gives you
pixel wise distances for the for the rgb
image so that should
get you close to rgbd and this is
very similar to the kind of work that i
kind of talked about
for you know detecting drones through
depth maps so we were assuming that we
could pull in rgb in depth
but rgb is useful if you want to run any
of
the perception models
so i guess we have time for one last
question
and the question okay so they just got
this question how do you build a
trajectory when you're not training but
you're testing
can you switch around the learning
aspect of the drone motion planning so
what you can do is so with move on
spline
right you're our focus in the in the
talk was with me once when you were
basically trying to learn the velocity
commands
but you can actually try to learn the
trajectory itself right so if you wanted
to come up with collision avoidance
trajectories
you could have move one spin at the
ground trip and you train on the one
spline and then you train
uh so you can understand how to fit
these trajectories and then at test time
you basically just spin it spin this up
and based on the environment and based
on
your location the obstacle's location
your trajectory planner would be like a
learned
trajectory model right so and then you
know you're just replacing multiplying
with your own version with it
so in the interest of time i would i
will have to
end here i'm sorry i'm not able to take
most of the other questions but feel
free to you know open up issues on the
github repo
and we can we can have more discussions
over there
and so again thank you all for attending
and then sticking around for the q a
we really appreciate your participation
and the interest you know
in this in the subject so again uh
please go take a look at the resource
list on the right this will have links
to all the github repositories that i
talked about as well as all the papers
that i i talked about and special thanks
to all the researchers who agreed to
showcase the research in the stock
and we we have links to the airsim drone
racing lab as well as airsim itself
and then you can look at the look at the
repos you can open up issues look at the
source code
read some of the papers and then we
really look forward to seeing
you know how you use this research and
how you build upon it and you know
evolve ai and robotics because i
strongly believe that is the future
again thank you very much and have a
great day